la provincia de columbia británica
desarrolló días pasados un ejercicio de
prevención cínica porque la provincia de
columbia británica minorista y
canadiense tiene estos ejercicios carlos
bueno yo creo que la provincia de
british columbia realiza este tipo de
ejercicios de prevención de de sismos
porque sabemos que estamos expuestos a
un riesgo de sismo considerable no sobre
todo comparado con con otras regiones de
canadá entonces es una oportunidad para
recordarle a la población que esto es
real y que hay que saber estar estar
preparado y esta jornada que se llevó a
cabo un par de semanas atrás en qué
consiste qué es lo que se realiza pues
esta jornada del grades y que en x y que
también se hace en otras partes del
mundo sobre todo en la costa oeste de
eeuu como te digo es una una oportunidad
para para que la gente practique cómo
responder ante un gran terremoto y yo
creo que el ejercicio principal de esta
actividad es que todo el mundo
acuerde de este drop cover and hold que
son las tres cosas que tenemos que hacer
si experimentamos un gran terremoto que
en español sería agacharse no tirarse al
suelo y cubrirse la cabeza si puedes
meterte debajo de una mesa algún objeto
así es bastante estable y luego
agarrarse hasta que termine el temblor
entonces esa es la idea principal de
este ejercicio que todo el mundo
individualmente sepa que esas esas son
las cosas que tienen que hacer en
elemento de un gran terremoto y esta
jornada este ejercicio como tú dices a
quién va dirigido a toda la población en
general algún grupo en particular
adultos niños empleados públicos quienes
están involucrados pues en este
ejercicio en particular es para la
población es para todo el mundo para
familias para para gente mayor para
trabajadores para niños en los colegios
entonces en cualquier contexto está
abierto que todo el mundo participe no y
de hecho es una actividad voluntaria
creo que en este ejercicio pasado
vi si hubo mucha gente que participó
cerca de 750.000 personas que es
bastante gente no no
no todo el mundo no deberían ser ser más
deberíamos participar todo yo creo pero
pero mucha gente y creo que el tipo de
actividad también depende un poco de
cada individuo y de cada organización
entonces si hay colegios que deciden
hacerlo a lo mejor a parte del rock
kourou de agacharse cubrirse y agarrarse
a mejorarse en otro tipo de simulacros y
dos ejercicios son lo mejor en las
oficinas también lo hacen entonces es un
poco y sobre todo el mínimo ese de
practicar ese ejercicio no y luego si se
quiere hacer más se puede hacer más no
creo que a nivel familiar es una gran
oportunidad para revisar los planes de
emergencia para que los padres sepan qué
hacer con los niños cómo contactar a los
niños y si están en el colegio y ellos
en el trabajo y ejercicios de ese tipo
entonces es sobre todo informativo y
creo que la gente sí que está dándose
cuenta de que es una buena actividad
como te digo setecientas cincuenta mil
personas solo si es un buen número pero
esperemos que con el tiempo no y con los
años eso vaya vaya creciendo ahora como
tú me decías días pasados este ejercicio
se lleva a cabo periódicamente todos los
años no solamente en columbia británica
perdón en otros lados también pero
también es cierto que el nombre de la
jornada que es una jornada de prevención
o las mismas características sorprenden
un poco en el contexto del resto de
canadá aquí en canadá en términos
generales generalizando por supuesto no
solemos pensar en una real posibilidad
de un gran terremoto sin embargo tú me
comentabas días pasados que esa
posibilidad si existe aunque no sea
inminente
víctor sí sí sí sí exacto la verdad es
que él reinoso y con canadá sobre todo
en la costa oeste es es considerable y
creo que estaba jornada de la que
hablamos es especialmente importante
para nosotros porque a diferencia de
otras regiones del mundo que sí que
tienen actividad sísmica creo que uno de
los problemas para nosotros en esta zona
de british columbia es que no tenemos
terremotos más pequeños con la
suficiente frecuencia para recordarnos
que es territorial entonces el tipo de
terremotos que tenemos aquí a lo mejor
pasa con menos frecuencia pero puede ser
un terremoto de gran envergadura no
podemos llegar a experimentar terremotos
de magnitud 9 del tipo que vimos en
japón
allá en el año 2011 entonces el riesgo
es real y creo que parte del problema es
que por como no tenemos esos pequeños
temblores que a lo mejor tienen en en
zonas en el sur de california o en chile
o en nueva zelanda que sirve como
recordatorio de que de que son un riesgo
real
el problema es que como no tenemos eso
aquí pues a veces se nos olvida o
pensamos que es algo que no puede
suceder pero la realidad es bien
distinta ahí y sí que podemos
experimentar un gran terremoto y por eso
hay que estar preparado y por eso creo
que este ejercicio es es vital y nos
ayuda a poder responder adecuadamente
para cuando ocurra un sismo de la
envergadura quien en la zona oeste de
canadá y tú me decías también carlos en
nuestra conversación previa que el
riesgo es real porque de hecho el oeste
canadiense particularmente columbia
británica pero no solamente esa
provincia se asienta sobre la misma
fallan los números recuerdo ahora si es
exactamente es el término que se debe
utilizar en la que está asentada también
el territorio del este de eeuu donde el
riesgo de terremoto es como más presente
no es cierto
si la verdad es que aquí estamos buenos
rodeados de muchos distintos tipos de
falla de hecho y de la que me estás
hablando tú normalmente se llama el
cascadia south tax johnson es una falla
de más de 1000 kilómetros de longitud
que está en la costa y que el que puede
producir sismos de gran envergadura no
este es el que puede producir la
magnitud del terremoto magnitud 9 del
que te hablo y esta puede producir
tsunamis también lo que pasa como te
decía el este tipo de gran terremoto
normalmente pasa con un periodo de
retorno de 500 años entonces el último
en los registros que tenemos es del año
1700 o sea que fue de hacer de hace
mucho tiempo pero el hecho de que no
pasa a menudo no significa que no pueda
pasar y que no debamos a estar
preparados entonces creo que bueno
vuelvo a repetir que esta actividad es
es muy importante para recordar a la
gente que esto es real que puede ocurrir
y no para para que cunda el pánico sino
al revés para que la gente reflexione
haga un plan y sepa cómo responder
y además de la preparación que debe
tener la gente también es importante la
preparación a nivel infraestructura
a nivel edilicio que también está
preparado a la provincia en ese plano
bueno desde el punto de vista de las
construcciones sobre todo si pensamos en
en edificaciones modernas creo que hay
que recalcar que canadá tiene un código
de construcción riguroso que está ahí
arriba con los de países avanzados del
resto del mundo y el objetivo de este
código sobre todo a nivel sísmico es
proteger vidas entonces las estructuras
hoy en día en zonas como la costa oeste
de canadá no y de eeuu y las zonas de
alto riesgo sísmico es diseñar
estructuras de tal manera que pueden
sufrir daños durante durante un
terremoto pero lo hacen de una forma
controlada y la idea es que tras el
sismo los ocupantes del edificio puedan
salir por su propio pie sanos y salvos
entonces el objetivo es sobre todo como
te digo al salvar vidas y que haga que
haya daños pero de una manera controlada
porque esos daños en la estructura
sirven para disipar la energía del sismo
entonces es una manera que está muy
integrada
en el código sísmico actual de muchos
países del mundo creo que el problema
está en en construcciones ya existentes
no ven tenemos una gran cantidad de
edificios que se construyeron hace hace
décadas y hemos aprendido mucho sobre
cómo construir edificaciones para
resistir sismos en los últimos años no
viendo viendo y estudiando
cosas que han pasado en otros lugares
del mundo atrás atrás
tran sismos de gran envergadura entonces
creo que que hay que recalcar que que
cuando un edificio se construye ese
edificio solo tiene que cumplir con la
normativa del momento en el que se
construye entonces si con el tiempo va
cambiando esa normativa ese edificio que
se construyó creció en el año 1960 a
unos 70 no tiene que actualizarse a la
normativa actual entonces con edificios
existentes sobre todo que se
construyeron hace unas décadas el riesgo
es un poco mayor y creo que es algo que
tenemos que pensar más cuidadosamente a
considerar digamos actualizar a
modernizar algunas de estas estructuras
y precisamente en relación con esto
último que tú decidas como experto y
como una persona que está trabajando
específicamente en el área más allá de
la preparación que me dices que tiene de
primer nivel la provincia de columbia
británica en ese sentido que son los
aspectos que cabría aún mejorar más allá
de las infraestructuras que están
perimidas que son viejas que no se
pueden por supuesto derribar de un año
al otro para volverlas a construir que
de lo que sí está disponible puede aún
ser mejorado para hacer que esos daños
que puede producir un eventual terremoto
un eventual sismo sean aún menores
bueno creo que es importante quizá por
ejemplo matizar o dar como ejemplo algo
que está haciendo la provincia de
colombia que es muy importante que es un
programa para modernizar las escuelas
entonces es a raíz de este riesgo de
sismo que como te digo es real la
provincia se ha dado cuenta de que hay
un montón de escuelas en durante toda
esta región que se construyeron hace
muchos años que a lo mejor no cumple con
la normativa actual y a raíz de eso la
provincia ha decidido invertir en este
en este proyecto o este programa que se
llama isi disi excusas minecraft tercer
programa un programa de modernización de
las escuelas y básicamente lo que están
haciendo en los últimos años y por
supuesto es llevar a unos cuantos años
más es poco a poco ir actualizando estas
escuelas para que estén un poco más
acorde con la normativa vigente entonces
ese es un ejemplo no que intenta lidiar
con este problema en los colegios en las
escuelas para proteger a nuestros niños
que me parece esencial
pero creo que tenemos que hacer lo mismo
con otro tipo de edificaciones con
hospitales con otro tipo de edificios y
de infraestructuras que sabemos que son
vitales y que necesitamos tras un sismo
de gran envergadura y más allá de eso y
esto es un tema que yo te estoy
investigando es pensar un poco en si
tenemos que mejorar el objetivo del
código no te decía que el código lo que
intenta sobre todo de salvar vidas que
me parece lo mínimo no es asegurarse de
que todos podamos sobrevivir a un sismo
y salir a propio propio pie de nuestros
hogares de nuestros trabajos pero creo
que deberíamos pensar un poco más allá y
quizá lo que deberíamos hacer es diseñar
no solo para que el edificio no se caiga
y que la gente pueda saber del sitio que
combina sino para que podamos seguir
usando este edificio para que podamos
seguir viviendo nuestro hogar para que
podamos seguir trabajando en nuestras
oficinas no entonces diseñar un poco más
para garantizar que el edificio funcione
tras el sismo más
de simplemente qué bueno que se dan y
con control entonces creo que podemos
podemos empezar a plantearnos qué hacer
hacer las cosas un poco un poco mejor y
digamos subir el objetivo que sea más
allá de proteger vidas y de garantizar
la continuidad de nuestra sociedad y de
nuestras vidas tras un terremoto mayor
recuerdo haber visto alguna vez alguna
algún vídeo de una construcción de una
prueba mejor dicho que se llevaba a cabo
sobre una construcción que había sido
diseñada específicamente para resistir
un sismo y lo que ocurría con esta
construcción era que ante el temblor
fuerte al que era sometida perdía su
estabilidad y se desplazaba pero quedaba
entera era como si fuera una gran
cáscara una gran caja eso es una
fantasía o es posible llevar a cabo no
no es eso eso es posible hoy tenemos
muchas tecnologías que a lo mejor no
utilizamos tanto como deberíamos que
pueden garantizar este objetivo del que
te hablo nadie
asegurarse la continuidad de la función
de nuestra infraestructura de nuestros
edificios como si piensas en el diseño
actual el que se suele aplicar a la
mayoría de edificios lo que hacemos como
ingenieros es diseñar ciertas partes de
la estructura como como un fusible y esa
parte de la estructura es la que se va a
dañar de una manera controlada y que va
a disipar esa energía del sismo entonces
esa es una gran idea es un gran concepto
de diseño el problema es que ese fusible
está dañado
tras el sismo entonces es posible que
ese edificio no funcione atrás tras el
sismo pues porque tiene un daño severos
a lo mejor se ha desplazado está
inclinado y hay daños que no que no
permiten que que podamos seguir viviendo
en la estructura y este tipo de
tecnologías a las que a lo mejor te
estás refiriendo y son un poco más
avanzadas y el código ya ya las permite
pero como son un poco más recientes no
no se utilizan tan a menudo como
deberíamos por qué
en realidad te pueden permitir
básicamente lo que te digo asegurarte de
que el edificio se desplace y hay
tecnologías que pueden estar permitir
digamos desconectar un poco el
movimiento del edificio desde el suelo y
aunque el suelo se mueva mucho el
edificio se mueve de una manera mucho
más controlada como dices tú casi como
una caja rígida y tenés en sismos
prácticamente no tiene no tiene daños no
tiene daños muy muy leves y como éste
hay un montón de tecnologías que
deberíamos intentar digamos plantear a
utilizar más a menudo en nuestras
construcciones carlos molina hot muchas
gracias pues de entrevista con un rollo
que no era internacional muchas gracias